des policiers sous le choc mais
solidaire après l'intervention tragique
qui a coûté la vie à l'un des leurs ce
matin dans la petite municipalité de
Bourget dans l'estontarien
c'est pas trop les gens sont tous figés
il était environ deux heures ce matin
quand des policiers de la Police
provinciale de l'Ontario se sont
présentés sur la rue Laval à la suite
d'un appel concernant des coups de feu
entendus par des résidents dès leur
arrivée le sergent Eric newler 42 ans a
été abattu par balle par un suspect deux
autres agents ont aussi été blessés
le commissaire du détachement de la
Police provinciale de l'estontarien
parle d'une embuscade ce genre de
situation mais les policiers dans une
position de vulnérabilité sont toujours
en réaction c'est difficile de prévenir
à 100 % les attaques contre les
politiques pour le moment la Police
provinciale de l'Ontario ne donne aucun
détail sur l'arbre ni le calibre utilisé
par le suspect Alain Bellefeuille
le chef du détachement de l'estonarien
affirme brièvement que le suspect
n'était pas connu des policiers
eric newler est le 9ème policier à être
tué par un suspect au Canada depuis
septembre dernier les chefs de police
pressent le gouvernement fédéral de
revoir des articles du projet de loi C75
qui a allégé les libertés provisoires de
ceux qui commettent des crimes violents
c'est du jamais vu à travers le Canada
on est très s'occuper par la montée de
la violence au niveau du pays ainsi que
évidemment la violence envers nos
policiers nos policiers d'ailleurs les
réactions politiques n'ont pas tardé à
Queen's Park où les parlementaires ont
observé un moment de silence et le
Premier ministre donc Ford a offert ses
condoléances la famille du policier tué
c'est une autre tragédie qui rappelle
l'importance de reconnaître le travail à
haut risque des policiers affirme le
premier ministre de l'Ontario à partir
d'Ottawa le premier ministre du Canada
Justin Trudeau a aussi réagi c'est
quelque chose qui aurait jamais dû
arriver on est là pour travailler avec
la communauté pour passer à travers ces
moments difficiles mais aussi pour
réfléchir à l'avenir les policiers
tiennent à rassurer la population le
suspect arrêté aurait agi seul des
accusations de meurtre et de tentatives
de meurtre pèse désormais sur lui ici
Pascal Robida Radio-Canada à Bourget
dans les soins